democrats pledged to stymie the amy
coney barrett nomination as judicial
hearings open
joe biden and the media team up to
redefine the term court packing
and keith olbermann is back and crazier
than ever i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in a
moment today is the day that the amy
coney barrett hearings begin but first
let's talk about how you can save money
on your cell phone bill so you've been
spending way too much money on your cell
phone bill why well you bought a plan
that covers unlimited data now are you
using unlimited data
chances are you're not because there is
no way to use unlimited data what you
actually need
is puretalk usa you can take a look at
that cell phone bell
where it shows data usage the average
person who switches to pure talk is
using less than four gigs of data a
month
the big carriers are charging you for
unlimited data which is like paying for
you know like
all the seats on an airplane to use like
us eat that's how pure talk
saves the average person over 400 a year
on their wireless service
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
all for just 20 bucks a month and if you
go over on data usage they don't charge
you for it
folks switching to peer talk it's the
easiest decision you will make today
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you
you save 50 off your first month dial
pound 2 5 0 say keyword ben
shapiro pure talk is simply smarter
wireless there is no reason for you to
overpay for your cell phone coverage
especially because you can get the same
exact coverage as you would get from
some of those bigger companies the
verizon's 18 t e t mobiles you get the
same coverage for like half the price go
check them out right now
now they'll pound 250 say ben shapiro
dial pound 250
say ben shapiro and say 50 off your
first month when you do
that magical thing alrighty so to
understand
what's going on in american politics
today you have to understand that all
institutions can be broken the left
believes that all institutions can be
broken why well because trump has
already fundamentally broken the country
and therefore
every rule can be violated every term
can be redefined
the entire country is now suffering from
trump derangement syndrome
in one form or another which is why the
return of keith olbermann
is uh is worthy of note so keith
olbermann you'll remember used to have a
show on espn then he was on espn2 and
here's something espn6 and he's like
msnbc who's on current tv who's a gq
magazine
he's held a variety of jobs he's a
rather peripatetic figure
so keith olbermann was back to lecture
you america
on why donald trump is the most evil
terrible horrible no good very bad
person
in the entire history of the world and
not only that
anyone remotely associated with donald
trump should go to jail
now for the far left this is like it's
kind of a mild exaggeration of the
left-wing position but not much and this
is why they don't care about court
packing it's why they don't care about
wrecking the senate
because the country is at stake and
everyone who disagrees with me
should go to jail here is keith
olbermann being very serious
and looking at you because he went to
cornell ag school
keith olbermann go the task is twofold
the terrorist trump must be defeated
must be destroyed must be devoured at
the ballot box
and then he and his enablers and his
supporters
and his collaborators and the mike lees
and the william bars and the sean
hannity's and the mike pence's
and the rudy giuliani's and the kyle
rittenhouse's and the amy coney barretts
must be prosecuted and convicted and
removed from our society
while we try to rebuild it and to
rebuild the world
trump has nearly destroyed by turning it
over to a virus
we must take all of these people out
and we must jail them and then possibly
guillotine them from kyle rittenhouse
to amy coney barrett they must be
prosecuted
i don't know why amy coney barrett but
she's bad even though i'm slightly
aroused
keith olbermann but it's this attitude
it's this bizarre attitude
that lies behind so much of our modern
politics which is we're at
we're at absolute crisis point because
donald trump
okay here is the reality donald trump is
not a threat to our institutions
you pretending that trump is such a
threat to our institutions that you get
to destroy the institutions
that's an actual threat to our
institutions which brings us to the
issue of the supreme court
over the weekend apparently you know the
craziness continued and that's not a
great shock
it's always difficult to have these
jewish holidays that last two days
because you're afraid of logging back on
and finding out what you missed it turns
out that while i was gone
the entire media and democratic party
simply decided to redefine terms in
basic english
so they no longer have to deal with the
ramifications of those terms
specifically they decided to redefine
the term
court packing so before court packing
meant that you were just going to add a
bunch of seats to the supreme court
in order to put a bunch of people who
agreed with you politically on the court
and therefore change the nature of the
court
it has meant this for some four
generations in the united states
in fact the last time the number of
people on the court changed was the
1860s
and it has been solid ever since in fact
it was so controversial in the 1930s
that even a democratic congress with fdr
as president refused to court back
but now the democrats in the media have
decided that they are going to
completely redefine the term court
packing so as to never have to answer a
question about whether they plan to
actually turn the judiciary
into an open super legislature so when
you talk about judicial nominations
when you talk about the role of the
judiciary you have to understand there's
a fundamental difference in vision for
how the judiciary is supposed to operate
so on the conservative side of the aisle
the idea of the judiciary
agrees with alexander hamilton in
federalist 78
that essentially the judiciary is
supposed to be the least dangerous
branch that is the phrase that he used
the least dangerous branch
because it had neither the force to
carry out its own judgments
nor the purse to actually fund itself it
was subject to the whims of the
legislature as well as to the efficacy
of the executive branch the judiciary
could basically make decisions but they
didn't have any way to actually
cram down those decisions and in fact
alexander hamilton said
that should the judiciary become an
agent of
interpretive creativity rather than
simple enforcement of the law then it
would lose its reason for being in other
words if the judiciary were to start
basically cramming its opinions down on
the american public rather than just
looking at the text of a statute
and then trying to hew as closely as
possible to the proper meaning of the
text of the statute
there would be a legislature and there
would be no reason to have unelected
people
in that position it would be an
oligarchy now in a democratic republic
like the united states you want a bunch
of different checks
and balances there's no question that
the judiciary
is supposed to be anti-democratic what i
mean by anti-democratic it is
it is a check on popular passions it was
meant to be a check on popular passions
but that's been true for judges since
biblical days if you go back to the
bible and you talk about the
sort of characteristics that people are
looking for in judges they're looking
for honesty
they're looking for non-favoritism the
bible specifically says that judges are
supposed to be able
to neither favor the poor nor the rich
right so it's not about
it's not outcome driven jurisprudence
the essence of justice is the justice is
the same
for everybody it is not driven by
individual circumstance
it is not driven by sympathy it is not
driven by empathy justice is supposed to
be the interpretation of the law
in accordance with justice right that is
what it is supposed to be
that is what conservatives have always
believed judges are there in order to
look at a statute that was passed by the
legislature
and then determine whether that statute
is in the proper reading of the statute
in the most accurate
reading of the statute in coincidence
with the constitution
looking at the most proper and accurate
reading of the constitution that is the
job of the judiciary
the left does not believe this the left
in the united states believes that
judiciary should essentially be
an agent of change and that is why the
left is always celebrated
the judiciary is an agent of change now
what they've neglected is that the
judiciary actively speaking is not
really an agent of change
typically this is something both the
left and the right tend to overblow i
think
they tend to think of the judiciary as a
sort of
a as a sort of movement forward in
american law
typically the judiciary green lights
stuff that the legislature is already
doing and then they refuse to stand in
the way
or maybe they push something a little
bit faster so to take a few obvious
examples
of sort of transformations in the law in
brown versus board of education in which
the supreme court declared that
segregation was unconstitutional
it still took an additional decade for
desegregation to actually practically
start happening in the south and that
was only after the legislature acted
in the civil rights act and the voting
rights act in 65. in other words
as gerald rosenberg says in his book to
hollow hope the the idea that the
supreme court
has the capacity to really change things
radically in the united states is not
quite right what the supreme court does
have the capacity to do
is to greenlight bad legislative
activity so that is what happened in the
obamacare case to take an example
you know so there are certain cases
where people think that the supreme
court has really affected
social change and there are cases where
it has right roe versus weight is the
most obvious case
where the supreme court decided to read
a trend and then try to
jump to the end of the trend you see
this in obergefell also
with regard to gay marriage where the
supreme court read the tea leaves and
said okay well more and more states are
green lighting gay marriage so let's
just go the whole hog and let's
put gay marriage right there in the
constitution i create a whole host of
problems you see the same thing in
abortion
via visa via roe v wade
the left-wing version of the court is
that all of these are the best things
the supreme court ever did
the supreme court taking a leading moral
role is the goal of the left but it
always has to be a left-wing moral rule
the goal of the right
is to treat the judiciary as though it
has a separate job from the legislature
a separate job from the executive
and its job is to simply interpret the
law
it is not the job of the judiciary to
create its own law
or to rule in accordance with its own
perception of morality that is not what
a court is designed to do a court is
designed
in order to interpret the law as closely
as possible but the left doesn't believe
this and to the left believes that if
the court is actually
if it becomes an instrument of
interpreting law and and interpreting
law requires
the striking down of particular statutes
the left doesn't like
or the court doesn't actively promote
left-wing values then
the court has been perverted and this is
why they oppose amy coney barrett
as we're about to see amy coney barrett
her hearings begin today
and amy coney barrett's opening
statement is very much about how her job
is not to impose her own morality
on the world instead her job is to
ensure that the law is interpreted
properly and the left really does not
like this if you look at the differences
in how sonia sotomayor talks about the
law she talks about the law is sort of
open-ended
and broad and malleable when you see
stephen breyer
justice breyer talk about the the
malleable
living constitution that you have to
move along with the evolving standards
of decency the evolving standards of
morality
and interpret based on essentially your
own
moral compass right that is a
fundamental rebuke to alexander hamilton
hamilton would look at that sort of talk
about the judiciary and he would say
okay then the judiciary doesn't deserve
to be a separate branch
we already have two bodies of the
legislature we don't need a third
particularly a third branch that is not
elected and that serves for life
but the left would love all of that can
we get to this in just one moment
because all of this
is the underlying framework the
underlying philosophical framework for
the debate happening today not over
not only over amy coney barrett but also
the debate that is happening over
so-called court packing we'll get to
that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that whether
your underwear is comfortable or not
that can actually determine
how your day is going to go and it's
small annoyances this is something i've
just noticed in my life small annoyances
can really wreck your day you know
things you don't think about
and that you just don't bother with and
then each and every day
you're like these underwear are so
uncomfortable why am i suffering with
this the answer is you don't have to
suffer with that get the best underwear
on the market i of course am talking
about tommy john underwear from working
to playing hard when you start every
morning in tommy john underwear you are
that much more comfortable so you can do
everything better
that's why tommy john underwear doesn't
have customers they have converts with
dozens of comfort innovations once
you've tried tommy john you'll never go
back i know because i have tried it
tommy john by the way so has my wife
with breathable lightweight moisture
wicking fabric with four times the
stretch of competing brands it moves
with you
not against you it's not going to chafe
you or anything like that tommy john
underwear comes with a non-rolling
waistband for the perfect fit
the legs never ride up you are covered
with their no wedgie guarantee which
definitely would have helped me
back in high school tommy john underwear
is listed on gq's latest 10 essentials
with kevin hart they have over 96
4 star plus reviews over 12 million
pairs sold you have to try them
for yourself and they have a best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantees
there's no risk try tommy john if you
don't love them they're free
get that much more comfortable at
tommyjohn.com ben say 15
on your first order say fifteen percent
right now at tommyjohn.com
once more that is tommyjohn.com ben okay
so
the hearing's open today and those
hearings
are um are basically a waste of time
they're a waste of time because the
democrats are just going to posture
about how amy coney barrett is terrible
and how amy coney barrett is a throwback
to to
a theocracy and how amy coney barrett is
somehow a handmade doesn't matter that
she's an independent powerful woman
who's going to be sitting on the supreme
court of the united states
we're going to get all of the posturing
from the various senators there are 22
different senators who make opening
statements today 10 of those
senators are democrats it includes
kamala harris kamala harris fans are
eager for her to get very aggressive i i
don't think that she's going to
i think kamala harris is probably going
to take a back seat on this one
the reason she's going to take a back
seat is because she looked terrible
grilling justice cavanaugh it turns out
she's not good at her job
she truly is not again proof positive
she's not good at her job she dropped
out of the democratic primaries despite
having at one point held the lead
she dropped out before there was a
single primary that was held harris is
going to attend amy coney barrett's
hearing remotely
because she says the measures against
covet 19 are are not
safe for her apparently a spokesman for
her said due to judiciary committee
republicans refusal to take common-sense
steps to protect members aides capital
complex workers and members of the media
senator harris plans to participate in
this week's hearings remotely from her
senate office
in the heart building her confirmation
hearings begin monday
senators mike lee and tom tillis both
tested positive for coronavirus senator
lindsey graham
and harris have been talking about
implementing testing measures
for members and staff ahead of the
hearings but graham has not imposed
additional
testing requirements a lot of other
members are expected to attend including
complete more on mazie hirono from
hawaii who is indeed the stupidest
person in the united states and i mean
she is truly a
and senator chris croons from delaware
he said that he's going to attend
physically and hirono will as well
tillis has recovered he's expected to
attend in person on tuesday lee is still
undecided will harris get aggressive
there are people who are urging her to
christian farias writing for the new
york times says kamalari should grill
amy coney barrett
they say millions of americans have
already cast votes ahead of the election
democracy demands one of the candidates
on the ballot be the democrats lead
questioner
at the confirmation hearing for amy
coney barrett that begins on monday
kamala harris isn't just a member of the
senate judiciary committee which
republicans control and is rushing madly
to ram through president trump's chosen
replacement for the supreme court seat
formerly held by justice ruth bader
ginsburg she's also one of the sharpest
questioners on the committee
setting herself apart in nearly four
years she's been in the senate she has
cross-examined everyone from jeff
sessions to brett kavanaugh to bill barr
yeah her cross-examination of brett
kavanaugh was this weird thing where she
suggested that he was in cahoots
with donald trump's law firm over at
cass woods without any actual evidence
of what she was talking about or even
any indicator of what she was talking
about
but democrats are rooting for harris to
get very aggressive
according to this columnist for the new
york times this is about democracy as
senator harris herself observed during
wednesday's vice presidential debate
republicans brute force effort to
confirm judge barrett as people head to
the polls
is an affront to voters we're literally
in an election she said over 4 million
people have voted
people have been in the process of
voting now
okay so what i mean seriously so what
that's a case against early voting that
is not a case against actually
having hearings to fill a vacant
judicial seat
but really what they are going to object
to because they don't actually have any
dirt on amy coney barrett and it's going
to be a lot harder to accuse amy coney
barrett
a catholic mother of seven of being a
gang rapist a lot harder to do that than
it was for
brett kavanaugh who was of course a
white male and therefore guilty of a
myriad of crimes he did not commit
they're going to go after amy coney
barrett on the basis presumably that she
is catholic and too religious
or that she might be anti-roe v wade
john pat horowitz on the commentary
podcast made a great point the other day
he was saying
we do live in a weirdly ironic world in
which amy coney barrett is expected to
opine on every single issue that could
possibly come before her but joe biden
is allowed to hide in the basement and
not explain any of his own viewpoints
one of those people is running for an
elected office and one of those people
is
being selected to be a judge but the
media have got everything exactly
backwards of course so in her opening
statement
judge coney barrett is expected to
praise her mentor the late justice
antonin scalia as well as honoring
justice ruth bader ginsburg in a brief
series of remarks
she issued a four-page statement and she
talks about her judicial qualifications
and she talks about her her sort of
judicial philosophy as well
here's what she says courts have a vital
responsibility to enforce the rule of
law which is critical to a free society
but courts are not designed to solve
every problem or right every wrong in
our public life
the policy decisions and value judgments
of government must be made by the
political branches elected by and
accountable to
the people she says justice scalia
taught me more than just law
he was devoted to his family resolute in
his beliefs fearless of criticism
as i embarked on my own legal career i
resolved to maintain that same
perspective
of course clerk for scalia there's a
tendency in our profession to treat the
practice of law as all-consuming while
losing sight of everything else that
makes for a shallow
and unfulfilling life she's also going
to talk about ruth bader ginsburg
apparently she says when i was 21 years
old and just beginning my career
rbg sat in the seat she told the
committee what has become of me could
only happen in america i've been
nominated to fill
justice ginsburg seat but no one will
ever take her place i'll be forever
grateful for the path she marked and the
life
that she led it is the statements on
judicial philosophy that interests me
most obviously
and when she talks about the fact that
it is not the job of judges to
do right it is the job of justices to
interpret the law this is exactly
correct
it is also in direct opposition to what
the left believes which is that
again the court is designed to do the
work that leftists couldn't get done in
the legislature
so they couldn't pass national
legislation on same-sex marriage or
abortion and so they have the supreme
court do their dirty work
for them they couldn't pass the
affordable care act
as a tax so they called it a fee and
then they waited for justice john
roberts to rewrite the statute into a
tax so that it would be legal
that is what the left wants the court to
be
the fundamental disconnect when it comes
to the court that has happened here
is that again the left would love for
the court to be a super leftist
legislature
the right would like for the court to be
a court and the left really objects when
the court is used as a court because
they see it as an obstacle to their
utopian goals whereas they would like
for it to be just another weapon
in their arsenal so
yeah amy coney barrett is obviously
going to cut against a lot of the
priorities that democrats
hold and she is exactly right when she
says that the court is not designed to
solve every problem or right every wrong
that of course
that has been a controversial line i
don't know how that's remotely
controversial it is not the job of a
court to do that it is the job of a
court to interpret the law
if the political branch is once we solve
anything they should solve the thing
when i was in law school i actually had
a little acronym
that i would text people when people
started talking about judicial activism
in class
which was l-i-t-t-l leave it to the
legislature
right leave it to the legislature should
generally be the hallmark
of a of a justice who recognizes that
the law is badly written and needs to be
struck down
or that a law is badly written and
doesn't need to be struck down but the
legislature has to fix the law
and the judicial humility goes a long
way a little bit of judicial humility
goes a long way
and that means faithfully interpreting
the law again what's amazing about so
much of this when it comes to
judicial interpretation is that nobody
would ever read
the the sherman antitrust act of 1907
the way that they
purport to read the constitution of the
united states and yet
more and more the left expects justices
to do this and you see even textualist
justices doing this
you saw justice gorsuch do exactly this
with the civil rights act of 64
suddenly and randomly reading
transgenderism into title ix of the
civil rights act
that's a bizarre absurdity it is a
fundamental breach of what it means to
be a justice on the supreme court of the
united states
but that's what the left would like and
if they don't get their way then they
simply want to pack the supreme court
and turn it into an overtly political
branch
and this is really what trump has done
okay what and really obama and then
trump
what all that has happened is that the
veneer has been stripped from american
democracy
that's all that has happened here as
i've said before trump is not the killer
trump is the coroner trump came upon the
body of american politics he pointed out
he said
this body may still be warm but it is
effectively dead
and the democrats are confirming that
each and every day it used to be that
they would pretend
that the judiciary was some sort of
a political branch now they openly
acknowledge that it's a political branch
and that they would like to cram it full
of democrats they used to suggest that
the senate was a deliberative body now
they recognize it's not a deliberative
body it is just
another way for them to cram through
their agenda the media used to pretend
that they were objective
now they don't even pretend now they're
just like okay well we're gonna pretend
sora will say we're objective but it's
pretty damned obvious that we are not
objective
in any way all the veneers have come off
and it's really ugly
a lot of people celebrate this a lot of
people think that it's good i'm not so
sure that it's good because at least
when there was the veneer we could
agree that the values the veneers stood
for were good
yes people were lying about what they
actually wanted to do with the court but
they at least attempted
to move in line with american
expectations of what the court was
with the veneers stripped away it
becomes obvious just how much we
disagree with one another
i'm gonna get to that in just one second
first let us talk about protecting your
computer
from malware if you ever had your
computer hit by malware it is the worst
thing in the world i mean it just
destroys your computer
if you if you work on a computer it
destroys your life for several days you
have to get a new computer
it could destroy your life altogether
because maybe get ransomware on the
computer they've locked up all the files
that you need and you can't get to them
unless you actually start paying people
it's really really bad stuff this is why
you need pcmatic
it's a next generation antivirus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware
independent testing from a v test just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019.
only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic will block annoying malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing
makes your computer faster and more
reliable even after years of use
pcmatic protects windows computer
including xp vista windows 7 8 10
windows servers macs macbooks android
phones and tablets
pcmatic is just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year the full theater 30
day money back guarantee if you act
right now pcmatic has offered my
listeners a free month of security
protection with the purchase of an
annual license you are making a large
scale mistake if you do not protect your
computer
from malware right now check out
pcmatic.com
ben again when you go to pcmatic.com you
get 50 bucks five devices
one year full 30-day money-back
guarantee and my listeners get a free
month of security protection when you
purchase an annual license
check them out at pcmatic.com and again
that is pcmatic.com
ben okay so there there was a veneer
that really st if you want to know where
the american people are all you have to
do is look at which directions
politicians tend to lie don't pay
attention to their actual positions
because nobody pays attention to actual
political positions if they did
i think republicans would win far more
often nobody looks at political
platforms
nobody even really looks at what
politicians do mostly people look at
what politicians promise
and what politicians promise tends to be
where they think the american people are
so even sonia sotomayor who's a wildly
activist left judge
even she when she was trying to get
herself on the court she suggested that
it was the job of judges to interpret
law and not make law
now of course she's on the court and she
knows that it's the job of justices from
a left-wing point of view to make law
to just do it willy-nilly but that even
when tonya sotomayor was being appointed
she paid lip service to the idea that
judges are not legislators
okay when it comes to the media the
media understand that most americans
would love to believe that their news
are objective and so media keep paying
lip service or did until very recently
to the idea of objectivity in news now
they've completely abandoned it
and you're starting to see democrats
abandon it on the court when they talk
about court packing what they really
mean is that the judiciary is no longer
supposed to be
an objective branch of government in a
political branch of government we're
just going to strip the veneer away
so we can't even agree on what the
judiciary is supposed to do we can't
agree on what our media are supposed to
do we can't agree on what our government
is supposed to do there used to be this
truism in american politics that we all
sort of want the same thing we just have
different ways of going about it it's
pretty obvious as time goes on we do not
in any way want the same thing
that the utopian vision of the left is
very very different from the
conservative vision for the country
and that the institutional obstacles the
constitution provides
are a real problem for many members of
the left which is why of course they are
now talking
about court packing now in order to push
for court packing in order to push for
adding justices
the left understands that it's unpopular
they understand
that most americans are not in favor of
fundamentally reshaping our institutions
so they just lie you've seen them do
this about the court routinely by the
way
not only individual justices who claim
that they are just there to interpret
the law and not to make it
and then immediately turn around and
make the law and not just justices
who suggest that judicial activism the
term judicial activism which typically
means
reading the law in alignment with your
moral ideals
instead of just reading what the text of
the constitution says that's what
judicial activism
used to mean they shifted the definition
of judicial activism they rewrote the
term
in order to mean any time a judge
strikes down a left-wing statute if a
judge strikes down a right-wing statute
that's not judicial activism that's
standing up for the constitution if a
judge strikes down a left-wing statute
that is now active right it's
activism you see the left do this
routinely redefining terms and it's
really perverse well now their new move
is to redefine the term court packing
so for several months now we have been
talking about the fact that during the
democratic primaries
many of the candidates talked about
packing the court even before rbg died
then rbg died and it became a rote
talking point for many democrats that
they would look at packing the court if
they gained control
of the senate now this isn't really as
much of a threat to biden as it is to
various senate candidates
the truth is biden's refusal to denounce
court packing is not going to hurt biden
very much
because the vote for biden is really not
about biden it's really about trump
but it could hurt the democrats down
ballot it could hurt the democrats
in the senate because those races are
very very closely fought
there's the significant possibility
right now and i think i'd probably put
my money on this
that the that joe biden is leading in
the presidential race
but in the senate republicans hold the
senate because the democrats have gotten
so radical on this issue so instead
they've decided to completely redefine
the term court packing and the media are
going along
with this completely donald trump over
the weekend he correctly pointed out
that the radical left democrats are
pushing joe biden to pack the supreme
court so president trump tweeted fdr's
own party told him you cannot pack the
united states supreme court it would
permanently destroy the court
but now the radical left democrats are
pushing biden to do this he has zero
chance
against them and biden so far has not
really stood up to the radical left this
is why and this does undercut biden's
chief message it may it may not matter
but it does undercut his chief message
remember joe biden is i am a solid
moderate
i'm a person who's going to stand up
against the predations of the radical
left i'm a return to normalcy
then why in the world is joe biden so
hesitant to condemn court packing which
is a fundamental change to the nature of
the republic
the minute do you have a court that is
openly political people just stop paying
attention to the court
the minute you have a senate that has
been packed filled with democrats from
new states
and then pushing forward a path to court
and then pushing forward any legislation
to the far left
the american people and various states
are just going to say i'm not paying
attention to that you've now rigged the
system
like truly rigged the system and joe
biden is not standing up to that which
is an amazing thing for a guy who is
campaigning as captain return to
normalcy
back to moderation back to the future
right then that's a weird take it's a
weird take from
joe biden so over the weekend here was
joe biden trying to redefine the term
court packing
so this has been his consistent message
last week joe biden said that he would
tell you about court packing after the
election
he just simply refused to answer a
question on whether he would go along
with packing the court he was biden last
week in arizona
don't know my opinion of court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
other than other than
focusing on what's happening now okay
that was him
just last week okay then over the
weekend biden was asked about all of
this
okay and this is clip five he's
specifically asked
whether voters deserve to hear an answer
on court packing and binding like no
they don't deserve to hear an answer
this man has nothing but scoring for the
american voter and scoring for american
journalists
he does not care about answering the
questions joe biden he's a lifelong
politician
he's never had to answer hard questions
when he has answer had to answer hard
questions it's gone poorly for him
so his entire campaign is now going to
be i don't exist
i'm not going to answer questions
because if i answer questions you might
write about me and i want you to write
about donald trump and he's openly
saying this to the media
and so the media like the good little
lap dogs they are are simply reflecting
it back at him it's incredible it's
incredible watch
here he is openly saying voters do not
deserve an answer on whether he's going
to wreck the third branch of government
sir i've got to ask you about packing
the courts and i know that sure you said
yesterday you aren't going to answer the
question until after the election
but this is the number one thing that
i've been asked about from viewers uh in
the past couple of days well
you've been asked by the viewers who are
probably republicans who don't want me
continuing to talk about what they're
doing to the court right now
well sir don't the voters deserve to
know no they don't disagree i'm not
going to play his game
he'd love me to talk about and i've i've
already said something on
corporate he loved that to be the
discussion instead of what he's doing
now
okay that is the most absurd answer in
the world no voters don't deserve to
know where i stand i'm wrecking the
third branch of government
because i want you to talk about donald
trump he's literally just giving
instructions to the media
don't cover this question instead i want
you to cover trump so i'm not going to
give you
an answer okay and then joe biden lays
out the narrative that has become
immediately the rote narrative for the
entire democratic party and many members
of the media and it's
unbelievable how everything's switched
on a dime okay he decides that he's
going to lay out a narrative whereby the
term court packing itself
no longer means that you pack the court
with extra seats
from people of your political persuasion
instead court packing now means
legally filling the seats that are empty
with people
who are duly nominated and confirmed i'm
not kidding this is his actual case
now the predicate for this case was set
last week by kamal harris so
in debate with mike pence she was
struggling for answers he kept saying
are you packing the court are you going
to pack the court you're going to pack
the court and she finally said
you want to talk about court packing
let's talk about court packing and then
she randomly started talking about how
there were no black judges
appointed by donald trump as though they
love clarence thomas over on the left
wing but this is a fundamental
redefinition of the term right
because when people are asking about
court packing they don't mean are you
filling existing empty seats they mean
are you adding seats to courts
to willy-nilly overturn the majorities
that currently exists
on those courts not a seat came open and
now you fill that seat with somebody
instead court packing typically means
you add seats to the court this is not a
change in definition it has been like
this for four generations
during the debate remember i laughed
openly at this when i reviewed the
debate the other night
kamala harris tried to redefine the term
court packing in the middle of the
debate
you'll see biden picked it up then the
entire democratic party picked it up and
then the media picked it up which is
normally the way this works
do you know that if the 50 people
who president trump appointed to the
court of appeals for lifetime
appointments not one is black
this is what they've been doing you want
to talk about packing a court let's have
that discussion
okay that is not what packing a court
means packing a court means that you add
seats to the court that is what has
always meant so now there's this weird
redefinition going on so they don't want
to answer the question
in which we equate filling seats with
people who are constitutionalists and
originalists
duly because the seat is empty and you
get to nominate and confirm judges
we're going to equate that with adding
five
six seven seats on the supreme court
which is crazy
okay so joe biden tried this line also
here was joe biden saying the only court
packing that is happening is happening
with conservatives which of course makes
no sense because conservatives are not
packing the supreme court the only
quarterbacking going on right now is
going on with republicans
in the court now it's not constitutional
what they're doing
we should be focused on what's happening
right now
and the fact is that the only packing
going on is
this court has been packed now by the
republicans
after the vote has already begun what
the hell is he talking about filling a
seat that is empty
when you have a majority in the senate
is not court packing that's literally
the constitutional process
it is not adding seeds to the supreme
court okay but this immediately gets
laundered
by the democrats into the media so you
see dick durbin over the weekend
the idiot senator from illinois who once
compared american soldiers to pol pot
here was dick durbin over the weekend
i'd meet the press explaining that if
you fill vacancies this is now packing
the court now
they think you're a i mean they do
they think the american voters are
morons joe biden openly says it voters
don't deserve to know my answer on court
packing
also court packing no longer means court
backing it means duly appointing people
to open positions
here's dick durbin trying to treat the
american people as idiots
american people have watched the
republicans pack in the court over the
last three and a half years and they
brag about it
they've taken every vacancy and filled
it did you know that they've sent
us and we have approved only with their
votes i might add
10 people who have been judged
unanimously
unqualified by the american bar
association do you know how many
judicial nominees came from obama who
were judged
unanimously unqualified none so we are
dealing with people on the court packed
into the court with
little or no qualification uh who are
going to be there for a long time
okay so this is incredible so the entire
activist left picks this up the memo
goes out the entire activist left picks
this out
sam berger who is the vice president of
center for american progress
he immediately tweets out conservative
court packing in one chart
and all the chart is is how many judges
were appointed by donald trump
which is 30 right that is the number of
appellate judges confirmed by the united
states senate between 2015
and 2018 is is 30. and then he tweets
out conservatives stealth court packing
plan
step one steal seats by blocking
confirmation of judges until white house
and senate are under conservative
control
step two change the rules to appoint the
most partisan conservative judge that
break next speed
so number one i just i'm really enjoying
the redefinition
of a judge who rules according to the
law is a partisan conservative
now if you just do your job as a judge
or a partisan conservative
you are in fact a wondrous human being
if you look into your heart for empathy
the way barack obama described tonya
sotomayor but if you're a judge and you
look at a law and you say you know what
this law doesn't allow this thing
even if i would like it even if it's a
nice thing to do then you're a
conservative
partisan that is the way they've
redefined they've redefined what it
means to be a judge they've redefined
the term judicial activism and now
they're redefining the term chord
packing so there is sam berger for the
center of american progress then you get
dan rather
who for some reason is still a famous
person which is pretty incredible after
he completely blew up his career in 2004
by putting out
a fake notice of george w bush going
awol
he's now regained a certain amount of
credibility for some odd reason
he tweeted out can we at least recognize
that court packing at all levels of the
judiciary has been the republican
playbook for decades
asking for merrick garland that's not
court packing
they didn't have the votes to confirm
merrick garland end of story they do
have the votes to confirm
the judges that trump is appointing
in what way is that court packing that
is a redefinition so dan rather tries to
launder that term
then you get ruth marcus over at the
washington post
republicans have no standing to complain
about court packing
because the 2020 election isn't about
whether to expand the size of the
supreme court it isn't about whether
democratic nominee joe biden states his
position on court packing
the election is about one thing a
referendum on the dangerous presidency
of donald trump no wonder republicans
are so desperate to change the subject
the future of the court now that
republicans are poised to cement a six
justice conservative majority is a
hugely important topic
republicans stole one seat when they
refused to let president obama fill a
vacancy created nine months before the
2016 election
now they are poised to steal another
okay it's not stealing a seat do not
confirm a justice
who is appointed by your political
opposition nor is it stealing ac to
confirm a justice appointed by a member
of a party
of which you are also a member if
democrats in response says ruth marcus
are entertaining the radical idea of
expanding the size of the court it's
hard to blame them
republicans have stocked the court with
one and soon two justices whose seats
they were not entitled to fill
this is slow motion court packing in
plain sight okay what you are watching
is an incredible case of gaslighting
it's just an unbelievable case of
gaslighting the media are now in
plain view and democrats are in plain
view taking the term court packing
and saying court packing no longer means
core packing it now means anything
republicans do and we don't like is core
packing
as we will see they're also going to say
anything that republicans do and we
don't like is unconstitutional which is
super fun
considering that the left scorns and
despises the institutions of the
constitution of the united states they
think that the senate
is unrepresentative and therefore bad
they think that the judiciary ought to
be a super legislature
they believe that the presidency of the
united states should be unbounded there
should be no delegated powers
in fact one of the reasons why i vote
republican is because while i have many
problems with the way that the
republicans have gone along with the
expansion of the executive branch
at least they don't fundamentally
despise the institutions of the
constitution the way the democrats
apparently do
okay the ap picked this up the
associated press picked this up
so according to the associated press
they're talking about steve bullock who
is the
current governor of montana he's now
running for senate against steve daines
we can all hope and pray that steve
janes wins that race here's the
associated press describing court
packing you ready
so it started off remember from biden
and harris redefining court packing then
went to kind of the lower level senators
redefining court packing then it went
out to the activist base
it went out to people like josh marshall
of talking points memo
who put out a tweet thread saying any
democrat who uses the term court packing
to describe expanding the number of
seats on the supreme court
should be smacked upside the head this
is not only idiotic politics more
importantly it is wrong
incorrect not what anyone is proposing
for the last decade republicans have
used an escalating mix of aggressive and
corrupt means to stack the federal
judiciary
in order to entrench power they believe
they will no longer be able to win in
majority elections if democrats control
the congress and the white house they
must take steps to undo this harm and
corruption
and the most viable logical path is to
add additional seats to the supreme
court
he calls this remedial so he says stop
calling it court packing it's just
remedial
okay and the associated press picks it
up and goes with it here's the
associated press
talking about montana governor steve
bullock so bullock over the weekend
came out and endorsed looking at packing
the court here is democrat steve bullock
who at least is honest enough to admit
what he is planning to do here
he says okay at least we'll consider
packing it i mean why not this is clip
7.
they have been trying to politicize the
court every step
of the way and we have to figure out
ways to make it
less political so i'm open to that and
that's anything from the judicial
standards commission
or we'll look at any other thing that
might be suggested including adding
justices
okay so there was steve bullock openly
acknowledging that he would consider
packing the court
okay and here is how the ap covered this
bullock said that if coney barrett was
confirmed
he would be open to measures to
de-politicize the court
including adding judges to the bench a
practice critics have dubbed packing the
courts oh the only critics who call it
packing the courts you see
yes we've been doing this for a hundred
years talking about this but only
critics
call this packing the court otherwise
it's not packing the court it's
de-politicizing the court you understand
so if republicans appoint judges who
faithfully interpret the law rather than
creating it from whole cloth
that is politicizing the court so when
you add seats to the court you are
de-politicizing the court
that is your objective associated press
very very objective stuff there
from your associated press so it was
amazing to come back off of jewish
holiday and see how the term court
packing has now been completely turned
on its head and redefined
so that court packing is now
de-politicization rather than
politicization of the court
truly incredible incredible stuff by the
way it didn't stop there
joe biden claimed that packing the court
was just he essentially said i'm not
going to answer the question and then he
said
it is unconstitutional to push through
a judge in these times because we're in
the middle of an election
he said it's unconstitutional so jake
tapper asked his spokesperson
you know you guys keep saying that um
it's unconstitutional to do this can do
you know what the constitution is and of
course she has no answer
you know people say sometimes i'm soft
on jake that's because jake
will on many occasions ask actual
difficult questions of democrats
here is tapper going after biden
spokesperson
he said it's not constitutional what
they're doing
how is it not constitutional what
they're doing the vast majority of
people say that they
want the person who wins the election on
november 3rd
to nominate the justice that's a poll
that's not the constitution
poll after poll shows that most
americans vehemently disagree with this
happen on november 3rd
that's not what the word constitution
means institutional doesn't mean i like
it or i don't like it it means
it's according to the us constitution
there's nothing unconstitutional about
what the u.s senate is doing
okay so that is of course correct but
according to biden now we're going to
launder the word unconstitutional
it's now if you don't like it it's not
only not if you like it it's not chord
packing if you don't like it it's court
packing
if you don't like it it is
unconstitutional if you like it it's
constitutional
which again this is all part of a piece
it's all part of a piece
every single element of american
politics is simply a tool to get done
what the left wants to get done
they have no respect for the
institutions of the united states they
don't care about the institutions of the
united states
in fact as it turns out it's not just
the institutions of the united states
they don't care about
they're they're willing to twist and
turn science
in order to achieve their desired result
and then blame trump in the process
we'll get to that in one second when we
get to covet
but first let's talk about the fact that
maybe you need to upgrade your employees
maybe you do maybe right now you're
looking to hire and you're figuring out
how what is the best way
for me to hire and you don't know the
answer well let's say that you had an
employee
named mark and let's say that mark was
very helpful in moving to your new
offices
great guy mark there's only one problem
all the other employees were complaining
because mark
every single day of the week three times
a day and in the middle of the night
took them to texas roadhouse
and they're like you know what we just
can't handle it anymore mark's got to go
i mean there's no way for us to imbibe
any more texas roadhouse there's just no
way
and mark refuses to listen to reason he
refuses to do it
you know we've got state coming out the
ears and mark keeps saying let's go to
texas roadhouse well then you have to
get rid of mark i mean then you have to
head on over to ziprecruiter.com
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's at leading job sites they
don't stop there but they're powerful
matching technology zip recorder scans
thousands of resumes to find people
with the right experience and then
actively invites them to apply to your
job
zip recruiter makes hiring efficient and
effective with features like screening
questions to filter candidates
and an all-in-one dashboard where you
can review and rate your candidate
in fact zip record is so effective four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day right now
to try zip recruiter for free my
listeners can go to zip recruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-ire
zip recruiter.com daily wire zipper crew
is indeed the smartest
way to hire okay in just a second we're
gonna get to
how the how the media and the left are
now twisting
science in order to achieve their priors
it's pretty impressive it really is
we'll get to that in just one second
first in case you missed it we had
another great episode of the sunday
special yesterday with daily wire god
king jeremy boring jeremy and i talk
about how we started working together
how we launched the daily wire where we
go from here so go watch over at
dailywire.com or listen on apple podcast
spotify or wherever else you get your
podcast
also it is baseball season the old glory
daily wire baseball bat
it's back it's backing better than ever
this is our limited edition handcrafted
custom painted baseball bat in blazon
with the daily wire logo when we first
put this bat out a numbered edition a
few months ago
it sold out in 48 hours that was when it
was available to all access members only
now
anybody can purchase it but inventory is
still limited so get yours before they
are gone
text the keyword baseball to 83 400 to
purchase your bat today
again text keyword baseball to 83 400 to
purchase your special daily wire
baseball bat the thing's really fun i
enjoy it text the keyword baseball to 83
400 to purchase your all-american daily
wire baseball bat today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so it's not just that the left and
the media are undermining american
institutions like the supreme court of
the united states and then gaslighting
you
right deceiving you about the nature of
terms you know what the term means and
then they just lie to you about what the
term means so court packing is no longer
court packing
unconstitutional is no longer
unconstitutional basically if they like
it it's all about
it it's all the good things and if they
don't like it it's all the bad things
well now they're doing the same thing
with science so they're blaming trump
for ruining science
now let's just be real about this
people's faith
in science surrounding covet has been
wavering since the beginning of this
pandemic namely because scientists i
think
claimed to know more than they did i
don't think that they spoke with the
proper amount of
of humility i think many of our
scientific leaders proclaimed that they
knew exactly what they were talking
about when they absolutely did not they
claimed that they
were sure of their policies when in fact
there was a lot of uncertainty
i'm very much in favor of being clear
about the level of uncertainty with
which you pursue certain conclusions
so i said at the beginning maybe
lockdowns are justified because we don't
know enough
about this particular disease maybe
masks
are not justified because fouch is
saying we don't need masks and then they
switched on masks and then it turns out
that the lockdowns probably
were not justified right it turns out
that that lockdowns have the effect
of lowering infection rates for a
temporary time and then as soon as you
release
then the infections start to move
through society but current lockdowns
are probably not justified
it turns out there's been lots of
conflicting science about a lot of
different topics but the media speak
with one voice as though the science on
covet is completely clear in every
respect
which is just not true and so that means
that we have been misled on several
different occasions
by a variety of supposedly scientific
outlets
right remember the lancet published an
entire study suggesting that
hydroxychloroquine was going to kill you
of a heart attack and it turns out that
the study was essentially falsified
that doesn't mean that
hydroxychloroquine was a cure-all the
way that
president trump was talking about it
probably it was not
but at the same time it was not just
trump who was botching that particular
story
it turns out that the battery of kovid
has been
uniform across all levels of government
and across all levels
of our institution the media however
have decided the only person who is
botching the rollout on coven
is from they keep saying we follow the
science we follow the science except as
it turns out you guys don't very often
follow the science
you follow the science when it leads to
conclusions you like and you don't
follow the science when it leads to
conclusions
you don't and you're critical of trump
no matter what he says if trump had come
out and said hydroxychloroquine is bad
for you they immediately would have said
well the studies show the
hydroxychloroquine is not bad
everything is driven by trump it is not
actually driven by the science again one
of the great lies following the science
sometimes the science is conflicted
sometimes the science is unclear
it turns out that what science is really
good at is examining the past
very often it is not great at predicting
the future and that's particularly true
with a new pandemic there are no experts
in a new pandemic
and yet we are treated to this this
bizarre
sort of rhetoric where when trump says
something and it's wrong
then that is uniquely bad but when
scientists say stuff and it turns out to
be wrong
then they are not held to account for it
at all that is not a justification for
trump speaking beyond science
it is a recommendation that we'd be
pretty humble in how we approach all of
the science from every available level
and that scientists
should do the same so the washington
post for example has a piece today
about how trump has undermined
confidence in government science
joel ackenbach and lori mcginley they
say in another era what happened
wednesday might have been viewed as
simply good news
two companies regeneron pharmaceuticals
and eli lilly have independently
developed therapeutic drugs called
monoclonal antibodies that in
preliminary testing appear to reduce
symptoms for coronavirus patients they
applied for emergency use authorization
from the fda
the positive development immediately
became entangled in election year
politics with president trump repeatedly
making false and exaggerated claims
about the new therapeutics he called
them a cure which they're not
he said he was about to approve them a
premature promise given the fda's career
scientists are charged with reviewing
the applications
this has been the 2020 pattern politics
has thoroughly contaminated the
scientific process
the result has been an epidemic of
distrust which further undermines the
nation's already chaotic and ineffective
response
to coronavirus okay well again it's all
about trump right
so this entire article is about trump
and how the white house has intruded and
how it's really bad that trump has
intruded
and i think a lot of that is true i
think the white house should not have
intruded here but you also have kamala
harris saying she's not going to take a
vaccine
if trump says you should take the
vaccine which of course is anti-science
because trump ain't the one who's
developing the vaccine
okay also it turns out that we've been
getting conflicting information from the
scientific community all the way along
first the who said that this thing was
not airborne then the who said this
thing was not human to human
transmissible
then the who said that masks were bad
then the who said the masks were good
then the who suggested that perhaps
lockdowns were justified
now dr david namara the wh special envoy
is saying that we should never be using
lockdowns because they are not in fact
an effective tool
at containing the pandemic here was dr
david nabarro
over the weekend explaining lockdowns
are dumb we really do have to learn
how to coexist with this virus
in a way that doesn't require constant
closing down of economies but at the
same time
in a way that is not associated
with high levels of suffering and death
it's what we're calling the middle path
and the middle path
uh is about being able to hold
the virus at bay whilst keeping
economic and social life going and so
now
this oho is anti-lockdown so forgive
everybody for being a little bit
confused
and let's not pretend that if trump were
not in office that people would be less
confused
they are not there's mass confusion
raining in europe there's confusion
ranging across the middle east
there's confusion nearly everywhere
about exactly how to handle this thing
what it constitutes how dangerous it is
i mean there's actual riots in the
streets in israel there have been riots
in the streets in france there have been
riots in the streets in
the uk none of that has anything to do
with trump one of the things that has
happened with regard to our scientific
institutions
is that they have politicized themselves
once again i think that trump
exacerbates the problems here but i
don't think that trump
is the creator of the problem inside our
scientific community
one problem is that our politicians
politicize science the other problem is
that our scientists politicize science
and they get involved in making
political judgments about science so
perfect case in point
so anthony fauci said early on in the
pandemic in an interview
he said that the trump administration
was doing the most of any administration
he could imagine
which was true again if you if you look
at what the trump administration has
done
not what trump has said not the idiotic
rhetoric if you look at what the trump
administration has actually done
namely making sure that everybody could
get the ventilators they need mobilizing
navy ships to go off the coast
of new york ensuring that ppe were
distributed
developing operation warp speed we could
get the fastest vaccine literally in
human history because of operation
warp speed the government backing of the
development of new therapeutics that
have radically reduced the rate of death
from covet 19
down closer to to flu rates than
originally to
the who's suggested right the whole you
remember suggested that the death rate
on this thing could be three to five
percent it has turned out to be maybe
one-tenth of that okay
that is a pretty stunning response fauci
said fairly early on
that the that the trump administration
was
doing yeoman's work and mobilizing
everything so trump cut an ad in which
he pointed out that fouchy had said this
especially because
fauci is now considered sort of the
trusted scientist
although he's one member of the uh i
will say one member of sort of
private medical establishment who's a
very prestigious doctor at a very
prestigious university
and when they said that how did fauci
become sort of the epidemiologist like
the
source for all information normally in
in dr land people who work for the
government are considered like second
raiders
but in any case and that's not a direct
rip-on
that's him ripping voucher i don't know
enough to to say
what is a what is considered you know
the grand level of expertise in any case
fauci himself said that trump had done
the trump administration had done a good
job mobilizing the resources so trump
cut an ad this way
and then fauci inserted himself right
into the politics so again it's not just
politicians who politicize the science
it is scientists who have politicized
the science it was trump cutting an ad
there's nothing wrong with this ad the
ad is fine
president trump is recovering from the
coronavirus
and so is america together we rose to
meet the challenge
protecting our seniors getting them
life-saving drugs in record time
sparing no expense president trump
tackled the virus head-on
as leaders should i can't imagine that
anybody could be doing more we'll get
through this together
we'll live carefully but not afraid
i'm donald j trump and i approve this
message okay so fouchy then came out and
said it was inaccurate
fauci said they're taking my words out
of context why because he wasn't talking
about trump personally he was talking
about the federal employees yes but
who's the head of the government
like i'm sorry but that is not an
inaccurate ad if you say
that i can't imagine anybody doing more
about the obama administration that
obama cuts an ad where it says i can't
imagine anybody doing more
where no one would be objecting but
because trump is saying it suddenly it's
objectionable
again the scientists have been pretty
political throughout this entire process
i will say it is not just politicians
now meanwhile our cultural institutions
are similarly under assault so we have
our governmental institutions
then we have science which has been
politicized every which way by political
actors ranging from trump
to andrew cuomo who by the way said
yesterday that he is looking at
additional lockdowns in new york state
after there were five
deaths in new york from covet five
that's a state of 20 million
people this thing has become very
political
okay so we've already perverted our
governmental institutions
we've perverted our scientific
institutions because our scientists are
considered
the font head of all knowledge and many
of them are not exhibiting the sort of
scientific caution that would be
recommended
in any normal scientific scenario okay
and now
we are going to pervert every aspect of
our culture as well
like literally every aspect of our
culture and our media are going to
engage
in this so here specifically i got to
talk about two articles
in the new york times because this is
really impressive stuff
so over the weekend brett stevens had an
excellent column in the new york times i
know
an excellent column in the new york
times a sentence that is very rarely
uttered
he had a piece called the 16-19
chronicles and he talks about the fact
that the 1619 project has now rewritten
its own history
to suggest that it wasn't saying that
1619 replaces 1776.
well that of course is a lie right 1619
was explicitly designed
to overwrite 1776. brett stevens says
if there's one word admirers and critics
a light can agree on when it comes to
the new york times award-winning 1619
project
its ambition ambition to reframe
america's conversation about race
ambition to reframe our understanding of
history ambition to move
from news pages to classrooms ambition
to move from scholarly debate to
national consciousness
in some ways this ambition succeeded the
1619 project introduced a date
previously obscured to most americans
that ought
always to have been thought of as
seminal and probably now will it offered
fresh reminders of the extent
which black freedom was a victory gained
by courageous black americans and not
just to give obtain
from benevolent whites but
it's but it also went further it went
further
ambition can be double-edged journalists
ours has breast stephen most often in
the business of writing the first rough
draft of history
not trying to have the last word on it
we are best when we try to tell truths
with a lowercase t
following evidence in directions unseen
not the capital t truth of a
pre-established narrative
in which inconvenient facts get
discarded we're supposed to report and
comment on the political and cultural
issues of the day
not become the issue itself as fresh
concerns make clear on these points and
for all of its virtues
buzz spin-offs and a pulitzer prize the
16-19 project has failed
these concerns came to light last month
when a long-standing critic of the
project philip
w magnus noted in the online magazine
qualette that references to 1619 as the
country's true founding or moment
america began
had disappeared from the digital display
copy without explanation these were not
minor points
the deleted assertions went to the core
of the project's most controversial
goal quote to reframe american history
by considering what it would mean
to regard 1619 as our nation's birth
year
that doesn't mean the project seeks to
erase the declaration of independence
from history but it does mean it seeks
to dethrone the 4th of july by treating
american history as a story of black
struggle against white supremacy
of which the declaration is for all of
its high-flow and rhetoric supposed to
be merely a part
in a tweet hannah jones responded to
magnus and other critics by insisting
the text of the project remained
unchanged
while maintaining the case for making in
1619 the country's true birth year was
quote always a metaphoric argument
i emailed her to ask if she could point
to any instances before this controversy
in which she had acknowledged that her
claims about 1619 as our true founding
had been merely metaphorical
her answer was that the idea of treating
the 16-19 date metaphorically should
have been so obvious it went without
saying
she then challenged me to find any
instance in which the project stated
that using 1776 as our country's birth
date is wrong that should not be taught
to school children and that the only one
that should be taught was 1619
good luck unearthing any of us arguing
that she added here is an excerpt from
the introductory essay to the project
by the new york times magazine's editor
quote 16-19
it is not a year that most americans
know as a notable date in our country's
history
those who do are at most a tiny fraction
of those who can tell you that 1776
is the year of our nation's birth what
if however we were to tell you that this
fact which is taught in our schools and
unanimously celebrated every fourth of
july is wrong
and that the country's true birth date
the moment that its defining
contradictions first came into the world
was in late august
of 1619 now they have cut that out
now they've cut that out this is what
the new text says 1619 is naughty or
most americans know as a notable date in
our country's history
those who do are at most a tiny fraction
of those who can tell you 1776 is the
year of our nation's birth
what if however we were to tell you the
moment the country's defining
contradictions first came into the world
was in late august 1619
what they left out was that the fact
that we were taught that 1776 is the
founding date is wrong and that the
country's
true birth date is 16 19. and so brett
stephens points this out
and he suggests that this is
historically wrong this led
to the new york times guild which is the
union of writers over the new york times
to tweet out in bizarre fashion quote it
says a lot about an organization when it
breaks its own rules and goes after one
of its own
the act like the article reeks okay so a
couple of things one
um you are currently attacking a new
york times writer two
they don't know how to use the word it's
okay it is not a possessive
okay but in any case they then tweeted
out we deleted
our previous tweet it was tweeted an
error we apologized for the mistake what
you will notice
is that two days elapsed between them
putting up that tweet and them
and them taking down the tweet so in
other words it's very bad
to point out that the 1619 project is a
ball of crap
you can't point that out what you can do
is rip on a writer at the new york times
who points this thing out
the rewriting of our cultural
institutions is occurring wholesale
by motivated political actors who have
no interest in journalism
by journalists who refuse to dog joe
biden on whether he's going to court pac
by journalists who are happy to go along
with the redefinition of court packing
and by journalists who refuse to ask
simple questions like why were you
allowed to rewrite the chief mechanism
and chief goal
of the 1619 project okay so that's one
example of the new york times rewriting
reality
in bizarre ways okay another way in
which the new york times is rewriting
reality in bizarre ways so this is an
insane article from the new york times
today it's from the book review section
they are reviewing a book by a woman
named jane ward
put out by new york university it's
called the tragedy of heterosexuality
this is where things get real weird
again this is all the new york times
just promoting cultural propaganda from
the
jacques the deconstruction is left it's
bizarre
the tragedy of heterosexuality wastes
absolutely no time getting to the point
while many of its sentences made me
laugh out loud it is at heart a somber
urgent academic examinations of the many
ways in which
opposite sex coupling can hurt the very
individuals who cling to it most okay so
now the new york times book review
is literally pushing a book that argues
that heterosexuality is in and of itself
bad
not only it only perpetuates the species
it only provides solid family structures
for children
but it's bad it's inherently bad here is
what the new york times review of books
says
the new york times book review ward
distinguishes straightness as a practice
from straight culture
which is at the very heart of society's
most disgraceful failures straight
culture
is at the heart of society's most
disgraceful failures you see
it is not as one popular joke was that
straight people are not okay
it is that heteronormativity creates a
powerful privileged form of sexuality
against which historically and currently
all other forms are compared in
examining the pressure to partner with
the opposite gender we find the
extortions of capitalism
the misogyny of violence against women
the racist and xenophobic erasure of
non-white families and the homophobic
hatreds that purvey
so much of everyday life so
if you're straight and if we see
straight culture
and like being straight as something
good
because it propagates the species and
creates families
naturally through the general biological
process
this means that you are participating in
let me quote this the extortions of
capitalism
i i didn't realize that that a man
having sex with a woman
was about the extortion of capitalism
that the consensual
exchange there was it was about was
about
capitalism per se it seems like lots of
kami countries still have heterosexuals
in them
the misogyny of violence against women
and so now we are back to the old
feminist
chestnut that all penetrate of sex is a
form of rape or some such nonsense
the racist and xenophobic erasure of
non-white families
okay that's confusing so it turns out
that being straight has to do with
saying that black families don't exist
which is
weird and the homophobic hatreds that
pervade so much of everyday life
so in other words if you say that
heterosexuality is good that means that
you have to be
nasty to gay and lesbians which is which
is weird because it seems like
vast majority of straight people in the
united states very friendly toward gays
and lesbians
this is the new york times rewriting our
cultural norms and institutions
our desires may feel beyond our control
but ward stresses the importance of
understanding sexuality as
self-identified
one of the foundational principles of
lesbian feminism is that each person's
sexual desire is their own
responsibility says ward
if not something they can choose then at
least something they can choose to
examine and take ownership of
as such she argues a queer theory might
be just the thing to
rescue heterosexuality from its unearned
hegemony in our shared cultural
imagination oh my god so this is the
culture they want to create this is the
culture of the left in which
heterosexuality is about capitalism
and forcible violence against women and
which 1776 is not the founding
of the country and if you argue that it
is the founding of the country then you
should be called out by the new york
times guild
these are our media members but don't
you worry they have your best interests
at heart america
they care deeply about american values
deeply about american values
in very real and abiding ways
okay we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow for much much more i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you